hallo ihr Lieben auf alte Zeiten wo ich
immer geklatscht habe
okay worum geht's immer hallo zusammen
wir testen heute
tiktok Hacks von denen wir gerade selber
nichts wissen tiktok genau tiktok Hacks
die Sarah uns vorbereitet hat unsere
Zaubernde Kamera drauf wir wissen halt
nicht was es ist und wir wissen noch
nicht ob es funktioniert lass uns
einfach überraschen dann mal her mit dem
ersten Hack die erste Hack zum erraten
Knoblauch schneiden
[Musik]
hörst du bitte auf das ist doch scharf
da muss es so sein
dass du doch nichts von wenn du das
schon also der Hack ist du hast es schon
geschält das heißt der Hack kann es
nicht sein dass du zerdrücken und zu
schälen okay dann aber darf ich euch den
Tipp geben das haben wir gar nicht mal
so schlecht war ich sag doch so aber der
Gag dahinter ist ja dass man sie man
möchte dass der klein machen um zum
Kochen zu verarbeiten ich würde jetzt
mein Messer nehmen und so das ist ja
kein Hack das wäre dann kein Hack haben
sein liegt nicht so falsch draufdrücken
ist nicht richtig das was am Anfang
versucht hat sage ich doch so rum mit
der Klinge nach oben damit die Aromen
drin bleiben das glaube ich nicht
ja aber andersrum die klar schneidet
mein Messer das bald erscheint gut aber
kannst dass du vielleicht das so machst
das musst anschneidest und dann rein
gehst aber ganz ehrlich
ja also ganz ehrlich also ganz ehrlich
so für Kirsche erfahren Leute es ist
wahrscheinlich gut aber okay jetzt ist
der drückst
also ich finde es sehr gefährlich auch
in der Küche gefährlich
Fake Fake ich sag dir warum es kann
nicht sein dass der schneidet und die
Stücke schon so klein war der hat das
vorgeschnitten er hat das ganz normales
ganz normale Messer genommen er hat so
Ritze reingemacht zack er hat dann so
quer auch noch mal ein paar Ritze
reingemacht
das so so und jetzt nimmt er es auf
jetzt drückt er das play
und dann denken die Leute ey das ist
doch voll unfair wie kann man so
genießen egal wie du warst und eklig
genau
man sagt bei einer Presse ist das Aroma
anders was ich bis heute nicht
bestätigen kann aber wenn es mit dem
Messer macht wie bei einer Zwiebel
eine Knoblauch was willst du dann noch
schmecken Alter das knallt doch sowieso
durch also wie gesagt wie war der
Zwiebel längst schneiden dann gerne auch
so schneiden wenn du eine dicke
Knoblauchzehe und dann die Finger immer
nach innen ne sonst schneidet euch die
Puppen ab und dann so wenn ihr eine
flache Knoblauchzehe nicht so groß ist
könnt ihr direkt Wiegen mit dem Messer
also ganz ehrlich
der zweite Hack Zwiebel schneiden ohne
zu weinen
[Musik]
ich kann euch schon mal sagen die
Zwiebel braucht ihr nicht die Zwiebel
ist der Gag wofür ihr die
da drumherum jetzt braucht also zwei
Becher absichtlich jeder zwei Becher wow
das sind ja tolle Becher wo bekommt man
solche Becher her bestimmt einen Kaffee
wow also zu viel Werbung
dieses Klebeband oder einfach nur Kleber
ich habe so eine Idee
also ihr würdet jetzt eine Zwiebel
schneiden und dafür davor braucht ihr
etwas und das sind jetzt die Becher
genau ein Tool womit man die Zwiebel
schneiden oder schälen kann weil das
nicht beides ist nein das brauchst du
für dich vorher damit das Auge nicht
drehen
aber es klappt gar nicht weil da kommt
auf jeden Fall durch ja ich komme also
ganz ehrlich erstmal habe ich gedacht
dass man das so macht so und dann steht
die sich von alleine aber das ist ja
nicht der Gag dahinter naja ist einfach
nur dass du dass wir zusammenkleben
dieses Gag dahinter haben wir von Sarah
geklaut von Fred nie gesagt
[Musik]
ohne dass wir kleben guck mal nachhaltig
damit ich die Mitte noch benutzen kann
habe ich den Kleber nicht abgemacht
oh scheiße also so richtig okay
angenommenes Held Hamza guck mal halt du
mir das doch auf die Augen und ich
schneide oder umgekehrt
okay
soll ich nicht einfach so richtig dran
riechen aber ich sehe meine Finger jetzt
nicht gerade weil die Becher mir voll
die sich
Drogen genommen
also eigentlich muss man direkt was
kommen weil ich eine große Nase genau
jetzt
was ja
also ganz ehrlich das sieht richtig
bescheuert aus und ich würde das niemals
machen dann würde ich lieber eine
Sonnenbrille nehmen oder sowas
beim Dreh bestimmt hinter ihr und hat
festgehalten ich finde es ganz echt dann
stelle ich mich lieber drauf ein dass
man so ein bisschen die Augen Wässern
beim Kochen das ist nur
Zwiebel auch gut
der dritte Hack Apfel mit einem Edding
entkernen
[Musik]
alles was zu bedeuten dass sich rot habe
und haben sehr schwarz Apfel entkernen
mit einem Edding ehrlich
abgenommen weil der hat ja dann muss es
bestimmt so einer sein der so Rillen hat
oder
damit in der Klasse hast du da habe ich
dir auch noch viel vorgesagt oha Fuchs
ja nicht es geht wirklich oh nein
aber das ist ja wirklich mal cool
[Musik]
ich habe letzte Woche im Video gesagt
ich habe keinen Apfelentkerner wofür ein
apfelentferner wenn man in Erding hat
ganz ehrlich ja das kann man auch mit
der Hand machen
gewaschen
sind gut im Kern muss ich ehrlich sagen
ich gebe sechs aus dem folgenden Grund
dass es jetzt einfach zerbrochen ist
wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel Bratäpfel
oder so machen wollen würde dann weil
die ein apfelentkern vorne so eine
scharfkantige Spitze und das hat der
nicht deswegen macht man sich den Apfel
da so kaputt so nicht ganz hoch nicht
ganz Mittel so mehr als Mitte so so 55
Grad nach oben
der vierte Hack Kuchen im Glätteisen
[Musik]
gehört keine Glätteisen sag mir die
Backen ist ein Kuchen Alter
wir backen das
ist jetzt Eisen angeht natürlich
deswegen halte ich die Klappe und lass
dich einfach mal machen also ich glaube
wir machen jetzt einfach das ist
eigentlich voll simpel alle Folien ne ja
die packen jetzt hier drauf ne und dann
und das Glätteisen das kommt dann so
oben drauf wir waren eine Stunde ja bei
195 Grad
nein wir machen diese Mischung hier
drauf und machen dann einen Glätteisen
das drüber und dann Glätteisen
also der Teig muss in die Alufolie aber
wie also das muss auf jeden Fall schon
mal so sein wo findest du normalerweise
ein Kuchen ein genau
[Musik]
ich bin der wahre backkönig hier okay
dann bitteschön
also portionsweise machen wir das jetzt
Minikuchen dann oder nein nein das ist
Alufolie die kannst du immer wieder
fertig das ist jetzt unsere Form
[Musik]
so dann haben sie was willst du denn mit
deinem zweiten mit einer zweiten
Alufolie
ich sag doch ich hoffe das geht auch
schnell ich habe Hunger
das Problem ist bei diesem Glätteisen
der schaltet sich ab wenn er merkt dass
keine a oder das ist nicht benutzt wird
das wenn ich jetzt drücke jetzt ist der
an aber wer weiß für wie lange und
warten das ist was wird ja so was
glaubst du wie lange das dauert nein
ausgegangen
super relevant äh wenn Weltuntergang ist
so mal richtig Bock auf Brownies sind
ohne Witz gerade
[Musik]
verzüglich ist ja auch meine Browning
Mischung muss man schon voll viel
Werbung nebenbei benutzt man doch alles
was wir haben ja aber ich kann das Kind
noch ein bisschen länger aber es
funktioniert aber ist meine aber es
funktioniert wirklich das ist krass
Wetten in dem tik tok wie du kamen voll
der cake und so raus und voll dick und
so fluffig ja
ja
am Ende erstmal ganz
andere das auch gehabt aber 100%ig
mir würde wirklich keine Situation
einfallen wirklich nicht indem man
diesen lifehack braucht ja
der fünfte
Schneebesen portionieren
lasse dich alleine machen und den kenne
ich schon
ja dann mach mal
also eigentlich mein kleines dann dreht
man dran und dann zieht man das raus und
dann hat man
woher kennst du sowas
also wenn man zu viel tiktok guckt
kannst du den vor tiktok ich schwöre es
dir ich habe keiner was gerade gemacht
habe als diese Augen gemacht hat habe
ich ja okay das ist richtig gehört
ich habe keine Ahnung ich wusste gar
nicht
dosieren
ich schwöre es dir einfach auf doof
gemacht irgendwas
man kann wirklich einfach dosieren also
eigentlich hat man ja beim Backen wiegt
man ja alles genau ab hat dir seine
Waage seine Schüssel oben drauf und
gucken noch 10 Gramm noch ein bisschen
und so gerade wenn man so Vorratsdosen
nein nein liebst du mich nicht
das ist der Trick dahinter sehen kann
der sechste Hack Butter mit einem Sieb
schmieren also das ist lustig weil ich
weiß nicht ob du dich erinnerst aber
egal macht erst mal machen damit ja weiß
ich nicht mach du die Butter ist hart
weil sie frisch aus dem Kühlschrank das
nervt ja immer so cool
haha der wo ist das wie das geht mach
doch bist du manchmal so machen oh geht
nicht haha Scheiße warte mal bestimmt so
ah warte mal da ist doch eine Spitze
warte mal ach so
also boah wie geil funktioniert das denn
bitte ey das funktioniert ja mega gut
auf die Nudeln bitte schön das sieht
echt aus wie Pommes an Käse das ist cool
das ist wirklich cool wenn du nicht eine
große Menge an Butter morgen ist echt
wenn du morgen
den Brot schmiert nimmst du damit
jetzt musst du dann mit dem Messer dann
rausnehmen jetzt ist direkt vor unsere
Gesichter das sieht immer so
unschmeichelhaft aus in der Kamera
funktioniert je nach Situation im Leben
gibt es davon
der siebte Hack Eier trennen
ja eins für Dich ein für mich ja
also wahrscheinlich ist das Ziel einer
zu trennen das macht man ja immer so mit
flüssigen Eiern
nicht schlimm aus meiner Hand ist ah yes
ist gar kein Problem was alles gut das
fühlt sich ganz eklig an aber haben
nicht funktioniert das hat nicht
funktioniert
du könntest keine Baisermasse damit
schlagen
nee das ist einfach nicht funktioniert
ja so mit der Hoffnung dass jetzt das
Eigelb oben bleibt
okay
muss vielleicht ein bisschen wackeln ist
das ist das richtig du bist einfach
drauf mal gut vielleicht haben
das hat jetzt viele kleine Löcher so
klein sind die aber gar nicht so lala
und es dauert auch das dauert andersrum
könnte man links und rechts schieben das
Eigelb und dann hat man auch ein
getrenntes klappt ja aber es ist halt
echt anstrengend und ich habe aber auch
noch einen Trick für euch wenn euch ein
bisschen Eigelb in Eiweiß rutscht kann
man das am besten mit einer Schale
entfernen nicht mit einem Löffel nicht
mit den Fingern das ist wie ein Magnet
ja wie ein mal gucken was man mit dem
ganzen Ei geht das funktioniert auch
zack nee feier ich nicht überhaupt nicht
null von zehn nein
[Musik]
natürlich viel zu viel aber man muss
auch sagen und man spart sich halt 0,0
Zeit im Gegenteil
der Butter in fertige Portionen
zuschneiden
[Musik]
also wir haben hier eine Box Butter ich
weiß es wirklich nicht
Butterbrotpapier ach so
ich habe auch eine Vermutung ich habe
eine Vermutung das könnte doch komplett
falsch liegen
vertrau mir einfach hier
so ne das hat der vor was hat davor
das wäre auch meine Idee gewesen aber
was hat man davon was hat man davon weiß
ich weiß nicht aber was hat also es
bringt ja eigentlich aber kannst du auch
so mit dem Messer also man hat ja nichts
davon wenn man das so macht das habe ich
mir auch gedacht hat
also ja aber er macht das bei allem und
dann habt ihr quasi fertige Stückchen
die man immer abziehen kann aus
brotlegen kann und dann kann man das in
der Tupper tun hat quasi ja dann lass
mal machen
oh mein Gott oh mein Gott
immer wieder genau das machst du mit
allem und das ganze Stück kannst du dann
mit dem Dingern in die Tupper lesen und
dann kann man sich das morgens einfach
abziehen
ah cool wer macht das ja nicht so
wunderbar Stück rausnehmen
Seite angefasst
zack oh nee finde ich cool ist ein Heck
ja aber irgendwie auch keinen
heckklässler ich denke jetzt die ganze
Zeit so irgendwie so unnötig dass jetzt
musst du zu verschwenden weißt du was
ich meine also eigentlich finde ich das
voll unnötig und man kann auch ganz rein
und ich muss den tiktok gegeben
und ich würde auf jeden Fall zehn geben
ja ich auch oder auf jeden Fall also
nee gib mir gib mir nix gib mir keine
guten Vibes irgendwie so weißt du wie
ich meine das ist so gut
so Leute Hand aufs Herz wie fandet ihr
das Video wollt ihren zweiten Teil oder
soll ich lieber mal so richtige Hacks
zeigen so richtig es gibt ja auch Kikis
kitchen Hacks vor zwei Jahren ist meine
erste Teil online gegangen ihr wartet ja
eigentlich schon lange auf Teil 2 ich
glaube das muss ich jetzt echt mein
Eindruck geben
auch zehn Jahre drauf gewartet also
schreibt mir doch mal auf tiktok Seite
oder nicht würde mich auch interessiert
mich wirklich interessieren weil viele
sind es nicht aber Leute ihr landet dort
früher oder später irgendwann greifen
die jeden ab von uns ist einfach Youtube
hier dran liked kommentiert fleißig
weiterhin dann bringt uns am meisten
weiter weiter
das freut uns vor allem wirklich am
meisten weil wir bleiben hier bei
YouTube treu und weil wir auch denken
Rezepte kann man eigentlich nur auf
Youtube gut in der Kürze liegt manchmal
die Würze aber nicht bei Rezepten und
nicht wenn man das halt so erklären
Schwester Armen
also bis zum nächsten Mal auf dickes
kitchen tschüss
[Musik]